benvenuti a questo nuovo tutorial di
biciclette dai ragazzi avete solo
bisogno di te sheng eccoli sono molto
fiero di me stesso perché l'ultima volta
ho scoperto che ci sono le mappe che
puoi giocare in questo gioco che si
generano al caso e ho trovato delle
mappe della madonna che era quello che
cercavo sin dall'inizio quindi adesso
andiamo a farne un file farmi solo
vedere
[Musica]
proviamo ragazzi con queste impostazioni
vediamo cosa ci esce fuori ovviamente la
foresta perché ultimato ho fatto solo ed
esclusivamente montagna a chiederlo che
vi sgranchiscono le gambe che era da un
po che non andava in bici che bello
lo sai che bel compassion che sono i
miei pantaloni viola va bene ragazzi
allora io non ho ben presente cosa
riusciamo a fare una roba decente
ok bella lì se non avessi preso un
tronco in faccia sarebbe stato
fantastico
ok però vabbè cosa cos'è cos'è successo
c'è un trampolino lì per terra vai o
chiocchio
occhio che questa è buona la donna
cos'ha fatto che il fenomeno un genio
e vabbè si devi andare davanti zio però
va bene se ti fossi ricordato di andare
con la rotta davanti sarebbe stato
fantastico
ok un fenomeno come andare a fare la
spesa regala come andare a fare una
spessa in sta roba
anzi adesso saltava da far la spesa così
bene ho cambiato un attimino non riesco
a vedere niente no vabbè al buio ma
siete scemi
già già con la luce è un problema figura
di al buio però va bene la pista la
pista la pista era lì la pista era era
dall'altra parte zio da bravo già fatta
ciao raga lo so non sono caduto
no vabbè legame al buio impossibile ce
lo dicono non al buio non si può fare se
già non v'è già con la luce non vedo
niente
faccio fatica a tale va beh già con la
luce faccio fatica che devo fare al buio
ma la vera che è impossibile lo giuro
porca vacca
madonna madonna aiuto stanno facendo le
cose incredibili ma devi scendere
tranquillo tranquillo fai finta che sia
giorno fai finta che stai andando da
nonna tranquillo bravo bravo bravo
proprio no no no no no no così non così
partita che sta andando a far la spesa
all'esselunga bravissimo così fantastico
è partita la musica veramente carina
almeno quello reca vacca
[Musica]
effetto ora cavalca ho cambiato visuale
che ho fatto mi sono salvato pur
cambiando visuale fa il perfetto questo
ragazzo doveva essere un pochettino più
interessante scoprirete alla fine il
perchè in teoria ci provo
l'oro da chi in quanto storto d'albero
l'android
la home to the tower va bene se riuscite
a fare anche questo il che non è male il
canyon ragazzi mi mancavano lavo ancora
fatto neanche nulla sul kenya nella
prima volta anche qui ragazzi ho messo
pendenza al massimo quindi non ho idea
di cosa
ecco appunto madonna perfetto occhio
a posto ma allora io comunque sarò
ancora non l'ho capita perché alle volte
mi cade anche se cado in piedi perché
[Musica]
perfetto
vabbè questa parte non riesco mai a
farla porca vacca becco sempre la
collina a sinistra al drop adro era
tutto carico anche col drop ma alla fine
non è andata proprio così
vabbè sentite facciamo anche la prendo
di lato per questa parte infattibile se
non lo fai in altro modo
o lo fai così io non lo fai perché non
ci arrivi lì sopra impossibile ma
neanche qui sotto dopo presso il
percorso va bene arriviamo alla seconda
parte che non avevo ancora visto a
quelle sono tipo rampe ma sei scemo l'ho
amato e vabbè
prima passare in mezzo ai cactus in meno
secondo me un cartoon si faccia fa male
ok ma dov'è il finale di astori facciamo
un finale suo livello
c'è il canyon dura l'infinito scusate ma
eccolo una vita e mezza di canyon va dai
ragazzi facciamole uno un po più easy
meno male questo un po più rilassante
perché nicchia solo fare cose ripide
minimi va in pappa il cervello va bene
anche un po così anche bello ma che
tranquillità
sì che poi non è una con uscita in bici
tranquilla e pero almeno comunque
ragazzi vi giuro che sembra facile
pregio come non lo è che c'è a fare
queste cose solo perché c'è tanta
dedizione da parte mia che mai proattiva
il frate questo sì che è un porca vacca
di salto quasi arrivato stavolta mi sa
che la prendo giusta e rega per me e
adesso sì
io madonna no non è vero è svenuto una
certa buono buono buono ci arriveremo
alla fine visto livello prima o poi
no non ci arriviamo ok rai
la bei ragazzi alla l'importante
abbracciare le transenne e poi l'aveva
dove di una rampa anche il cda non ti
viene di prenderla il massimo quindi io
la prendo al massimo e va angula frega
niente se cadi lo ho fatto il mio
governo
ok eccolo perché non riesco mai a
prenderla giusta
ha confermato fa chi ineggia quindi è a
quanto caso al suo gioco
no mi si scale fisse scollegato joystick
ok ok che perfetto
porca eva morta ieri nella staccionata
incastrata messi ha scollegato il
joystick per un attimo cesto giustifiche
da dei problemi ogni volta
porca vacca tra un cavo de cento
youtuber 4 miliardi gli iscritti non c'è
un cavo decente per il joypad non morire
non morire non morire non tua madre nord
è erba beh ok ma devo passare per forza
contento è se non ci passo secondo tipo
via posso andare via e si va bene ma va
a caso se non altro livello più in là
cos'è veramente no ragazzo cieco ac alla
fine della mappa cioè mi spara tipo
cannone porca vacca morta
va bene almeno siamo tornati nei pressi
della vittoria scavalca che male ma va
bene almeno ce bene a me non sono
arrivato alla fine dai va bene anche
così ma questo questa è una montagna
decente per chiudere la faccenda
facciamo la montagna perché la montagna
deve essere un di presente nei vini
dolci davis almeno una montagna ecco
tipo in questi percorsi dove la rampa
nati di prendere per forza anche se non
la prendi gli sfracelli
come fai ad atterrare dritto c come fai
da te ahu che così non devi prendere
alla massima velocità e va beh son
spericolato a bombazza ambulanza e vabbè
acqua park dove sta andando la mia pc a
posto secondo si è divertito con calma
ragazzi lo finisco solo con la calma
perfetto mi sa che questa non è calma
quello era un albero non calma però va
bene c'è il traguardo esattamente dove
dovrebbe essere che male
vabbè io pensai ragazzi non riesco a
farle come sono seri qua visto un genio
schivo tutto il percorso vabbè che sarà
infatti bile dai ragazzi facciamo i sei
ok ragazzo passando sopra le montagne
tipo il signore degli anelli per
tagliare tutto il livello cava piano gli
apparecchi veloce prospetto magari non
l'hai dal porca eva l'albero o ci sono
dei rifugi e bello tipo di zelda nessuno
faccio qualcuno qua dentro
ogni volta che vengono nasce dopo natale
vero meno dimentica ecco il traguardo lo
vedo da qui forse ci arrivò in un'altra
vita è però forse sarei piano piano
piano piano che c'è la morte che arriva
subito quando meno te lo aspetti ti può
adesso non sono morto incredibile
incredibile
guardalo guardalo
raga io ho chiuso con la bici sbloccato
di consigli avanti consigli ma sono tre
video che ci faccio sopra di due
consigli ti mai preso per un novellino
ecco appunto quindi ragazzi spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto spero che questo
tutorial su come usare la bici sia di
vostro gradimento come al solito ragazzi
visto che visito sento mi piace anche
per i soci al comando da dove studiare
se non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
[Musica]
e noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video
da ragazzo
[Musica]